so i get an email from a guy named bob
saying he spent fifteen thousand dollars
on bitcoin and he's absolutely furious
how dare you take
fifteen thousand dollars of bitcoin for
me i'm gonna report you so i'm like how
did this even happen
anyways we do due diligence and watch
what happened here for those of you guys
that are getting ripped off online
i'm going to show you something here
we're going to see if we can get a hold
of this guy
so a person goes on valuetainment's
channel this is our logo
and they comment below with
valuetainment logo making it seem like
we are posting it to somebody that says
i love the content
and says let's talk more then they're
putting their what's app number we're
gonna we're gonna call one of these guys
here
look at this one invest in crypto
trading with my administrator
valencia andrew with the number his
availability is on whatsapp
we kai grab your phone let's call one of
these numbers to see if we can get a
hold of somebody and then i'm gonna talk
to them
and see how far along we can go okay how
about if we just
call them up here's one of them voice
call see if they'll recognize my voice
okay they hung up call the next one
okay if he's not big normally send him a
message check this out here's the
message
he's got one of the number we'll call is
this valuetainment
crypto trading program
i'd like to oh look the guy responds
right now hello how are you i'd like to
find out more on how
to get involved i know pbd
has the good stuff let's see what they
say
okay so boom message here boom
good thanks for getting back to me one
of these guys will respond
welcome okay maybe it's the same guy let
me change the names if you go back
you can see here where john pearson oh
okay got it this is john
this is jp okay so they're doing this to
a lot of different channels
is there someone i can speak
to about joining
this program so so far we've got two i'm
not going to message the third one
because in case if it's the same exact
person doing the different numbers
is this program tied to valuetainment
so you have to respond to the guy in a
way that's going to get him to want to
get on the phone
can you speak can i call you
i heard about a tayments crypto
trading program that i could get in for
15k and i was interested what's today's
date by the way
april 1 14th okay so now
if he's the con man that i think he is
which we know he is
if he tries to lure me in to get on the
phone we're going to see how he's going
to react
this doesn't seem like
the same program all right let's see
can we lure this guy in the world needs
to see this because people are falling
for this crap
and they're getting them with krypto
because there is no they can't get
arrested they can get away with this
there's no way to track it no one of
them is typing
both of them are typing so it's two
different people if it's both of them
typing at the same time probably
company like the same and they got group
but there's like five people doing
people just typing
i'm his broker in charge i'm his broker
in charge of his trading account i
manage his training here we go
he just said something he shouldn't have
said i'm a die-hard fan of his
and trust what he has to say
uh-huh he didn't i saw one
of the response in the comment
and wanted to find out more
so we already know we got a con man here
who do you think send it to you not sure
if you are pbd's broker
if you are pbds broker i'd love to speak
with you okay so this is good to see
what approach they're taking
okay because he's essentially saying
that pbd left the comment for them
to reach out i see what they're doing
yeah all right i mean we're learning
their approach
so far on what they're doing look at
this
yep valuetainment whatsapp call me 402.
here's another one do you see it write
my broker arthur rafael ibarr on
whatsapp to earn huge and crypto trading
for his strategies
he's really making huge gains in trading
and that's the crypto
send a message to that number as well
use the same message and send it to him
he's got another one here
oh look at this they just went all out
here look at this scammer
let's get response back scammer to the
guy so some people whatsapp feedback
information this is a different number
has anybody typed back or no
see what happens he types and then it
goes away
can you imagine if they're being flooded
by so many messages that they get away
i can't speak with you because it's
against my policy and if you're not okay
with it you are free to leave yeah
wow okay got it fair enough
i was ready to spend 15k for the program
and my my three other
friends who follow his content wanted to
join me
wanted to join me thank you all the best
let's see if this gets his attention
these are these are guys that know what
they're doing
highly doubt he's going to respond back
what do you think they're based out of
you think this is u.s china yeah russia
it's probably india philippines oh he's
typing back
if he says okay he has gotten a hint
where he thinks
we are on to him chances of him speaking
on the phone is what zero out of ten
i'd say less than one percent yeah yes i
know
but it will not make me go against my
policy because right trading is ongoing
so i can't and don't make calls so bear
with me i will spark
with you when the time is due speak with
you when the time is due
it's okay i uh had one other program
that i was looking at which was
similar and we'll start with them first
thank you
i respect your policy you ready
he read it fairly quickly yeah it's
double okay
he's saying yes now okay
okay you know what i will spark with you
for just a minute
let's see what he says he's about to
call this guy
so we got him can i call you then
brother
a long flight it's hoping to teddy
the training
[Music]
so just let you know it's sending the
message that you're typing here to go
he's calling ready hello
hello how are you i'm good how are you
speaking it is is this valuetainment
excellent so i would like to find out
more information about how i can get
into the 15 000
accelerator
let program explain what you have like
misconversion notes please start going
through them
accounts okay first of all i want to say
i'm sorry for you i spoke to you earlier
i appreciate that thank you all right so
uh
i'll just send you some messages some
from some things you see
to be able to understand how to start up
sure okay just give me a second i will
send them to you right now all right so
it's nice speaking to you
keep in touch sounds good and is it
you know what it was wow
so pre-recorded every time you would
hear the ding thing
thing did you hear that thing in the
background so you ever seen that the
prank videos they play
when arnold they the guy has these eight
buttons i'll be back or you know all the
things they click
all they're doing is it's a pre-recorded
sentence that they have like 20 of them
on the screen
they're clicking on it and it's saying
it i'm sorry about the way i spoke to
you earlier
that is their way of winning you over
trust wow
they go at that level i'll enlighten you
a little bit
and give you the best assistance allows
customers to trade cryptocurrencies or
digital currencies for other assets as
conventional currency
this type of trading involves exchanging
one for another buying selling coins
where fiat currency is okay this is made
possible because the employee algorithms
of robots trading bots helps you stop
all losses
this helps you maximize wow i do
i'm going to call him back voice call
let's see yeah so question for you how
different is this than
than buying crypto directly from
coinbase instead of buying it from
valuetainment
oh so is this uh something where i can
when i open up the account with you i
can do the trading and by ethereum i
know bitcoin but i'm learning about
ethereum
can i buy all of them on the same
platform yeah yeah i can do that
and you can trade by yourself too oh i
can do it by myself got it
and is this the program that patrick
david endorses from valuetainment
really okay is there a website to find
out more about this or is it all
uh on whatsapp to
you how much do i need to put in first
to get started with when you open the
website
you see the options everything's
here can you give me the website i'm
right in front of my computer
go forward i'm listening let me send it
sure people fall for this he keeps
hanging up
what's funny is people are falling for
this how do you fall for this elite
dividend.com
elitedividend.com so this is their
website welcome to elitedividend.com
about london
contact
i mean it looks full on real
join us sign up fifteen thousand
five hundred dollars minimum ten
thousand okay so i'm going to call them
back
i am on the website and i'm looking at
the three packages smart funds smart
funds pro
and platinum plan yeah which one do you
recommend
[Music]
you know the last one to choose whatever
one you know that will profit you the
most
are profitable for you do you start up
your investment
you choose them all the plans there are
very good
whatever you choose we give you a profit
you understand that so whether i do only
five thousand or if i do fifteen
thousand
it's okay i mean either one of them are
any good it's okay okay so i don't have
to start with fifteen thousand today i
can just start with five thousand today
what's the minimum today
on the plans the lowest planning i can
start with it you don't have to start
with the most highest point you
understand that
so let me ask you is patrick david the
founder of this
you know what you are on the website
just check on the history of the website
check your date check everything
yeah but what i'm asking you is i'm
asking you if patrick bet david is the
founder of this
of course he is the founder obviously
okay so you work for patrick david for
his bro
i just want to make sure this is tied to
him because if it's not i'm not gonna
work for him my work here is to direct
you guys
so you work for you work okay that makes
me feel much better so you work directly
for patrick with david
so are you the person that manages all
his crypto account
yeah i'm not the only one i can't manage
i'm not a robot we have other people who
manage other accounts
wow you know this entire time i thought
he didn't like crypto so he's more into
crypto than he claims he is
how many brokers does he have working
for him
is it a different broker that works for
ethereum than bitcoin and bitcash or how
does he do it
so he has multiple people working for
elite dividend
how is it working with them what do you
think about the guy
at this point what do you do the guy
sounds like he's from africa the accent
i lost you for a second i was going to
ask you how is it working with patrick
where david what's his personality like
i'd have to tell you that between
employees i can respect that
i'm sorry i asked i'm sorry i asked i
just
is this headquartered in london or is it
headquartered in newport beach where
he's at
okay
so here's the crazy thing no one can
find out where he is
wow let me see here
no nothing meaning there is no such
thing as elite dividend
yeah i don't know if it's your side or
my side but reception is
it keeps falling what's your name again
what was you did you say your name is
antonio
you already know my name oh i'm just
curious and by the way
you're speaking to patrick by david so i
am patrick b david how many people
actually fall for this fraud of yours
of course wow
are you kidding me when you see this
what do you think about what do you what
do you think about this year
how do people fall for this though
people wanting to make money
desperation if they're not willing to
talk on the phone or they're not willing
to
accommodate or answer questions it
screams
shady to me and also just in general i
feel like whatsapp and
and bitcoin in a lot of ways have kind
of that skill that sketchy vibe of
if you can only contact them through big
through uh whatsapp it's kind of like
i don't know like i'll send you an email
okay so you just saw what happened right
now with this guy call them antonio you
know what my name is
few red flags number one i can't talk to
you over the phone
finally he said yes so we got on the
phone together after i said i'm about to
put 15 000
in different places so let me make some
time because my private my policies i
can't talk to he did
he hung up on me multiple times bad
reception area why don't you just go
ahead and register
find out for yourself how it is and then
at the end of the day
when i said my name he hung up and if i
call him back right now it's done
there's no way in the world this guy's
going to pick up again if i call him
right now right
but how much money do you think they get
out of people not not just from
valuetainment
i'm thinking millions a month because
there's no way to
to put your fingerprint on it so share
this content with people people got to
see this to see exactly how this is
taking place because they're not going
to stop doing it and if you and i aren't
too naive to not see that they're doing
this people that you know or yourself
are constantly going to be taken
advantage of
by what just happened right now